build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people
this is bdp building artist Ron muic
builds lifelike sculptures of human
figures out of silicone polyester resin
fiberglass and synthetic hair that range
in size from miniature to
larger-than-life he's unveiling new work
for the first time since 2005 in Paris
starting April and his pieces can also
be seen at the Art Show lifelike a
Museum of Contemporary Art in San Diego
Alice Finch from Seattle built this huge
Lego rendition of the Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry
it took 12 months around 400,000 bricks
to complete and it's built in an L shape
where each side is about 13 feet long
she took home both Best in Show and
People's Choice Award at Brick Con 2012
mitr stream is an electronic knitting
machine from 1998 that transforms tweets
into real woven works of art using
custom software and hardware it was
launched at the festival c2m TL where
people were asked to tweet using hashtag
knitter stream and the most retweeted
ones were knit into 120 feet of custom
designs draw after drawing his own
likeness on a peanut steve casino got
the idea to start painting celebrities
he admired onto them he cracks them open
and removes the nuts then grooves the
shell back together fills the front with
wood filler and sands them down then he
adds legs and paints them which can take
up to 10 hours and finally as the arms
he leaves the back untouched because he
loves the reactions he gets when he
turns it around to reveal
detailed painting Sandra is a
self-taught makeup artist from Sweden
that does very creative and impressive
makeup work some of her looks include
this realistic eyeball on lips custom
girl mustache decaying moons eye hearts
and his great Timon from The Lion King
and now for the Legion of real-life
superheroes by butcher Billy where
real-life bad guys become comic book
villains artist Lysia created two
incredible illustrations combining
dwarves from The Hobbit and Fraggles
like Mike Wilson aka coma niddy is a new
york-based educator and rapper here's a
song he did about antimatter where
Einstein also you were awesome hair
famous with the equation e equals MC
squared I have the ever wonder because
that really means what does matter in
energy of both the same thing using the
makey makey featured in game loot on
vsauce3 electronic music producer J
views recreates the song teardrop by
massive attack with a well picked out
assortment of
the official music video for a taste of
struggle by Atos has a unique animation
created by Simon minards the lengthy
pose they just do what they know
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo wo
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bidipi radio music
created and submitted by you guys also
check out your bidipi an entire video
dedicated to your creations and as
always thanks for watching be don't rock
funny play games yeah what kind of games
first-person shooters
yeah oh yeah your RPP clear RPG gibt and
what's the first RPG ever played
phantasy star 3 Jake first RPG well
that's an RTS isn't it engine fire Susan
40s mm-hmm er PG could probably be it's
one of the Final Fantasy don't know
which one you wear contacts yeah I just
realized that I know I try pretend I
perfect vision point is the first RPG I
played come on Mario RPG right and I
didn't even know what admit but I fell
in love with the fact that I could take
my time to like think about the next
move homeworld
remember that the Archaea era that was
amazing
I I would play that game all day til my
mom came home and so she wouldn't want
me to play games all day so I just go
outside and I write on my razor scooter
and talk about strategy in the game out
loud like so sauce video I'd be like
well if you put all your resources into
research right away that's great for
single-player but when you're going
against other people they I'm much
smarter balanced their neighbors called
the police and Stevens boys talking to
themselves like ass boy he's an alien
Oh Stevens man um